so welcome to the world leaders forum
it's really great to see you here
tonight this is where artists and
scientists and scholars are invited to
Columbia to present important social
issues for discussion we're very
grateful to the president's office for
working so closely with us and helping
us to bring such a fabulous artist to
columbia tonight isaac julien will be
our first melon fellow in our melon
artists and thinkers series were really
honored and delighted to have him here
I'd of course like to thank the mellon
Foundation for its support for helping
us to bring isaac julien to the world
leaders forum and to campus and to
enable us to have him here for some time
during this semester and again in the
spring it's really fantastic he spent
last weekend working with students he
discussed Hills films he discussed their
films he discussed film theory and
technique he showed them the range of
what he has done and of course the
possibility of what they also might do
they're really lucky students I think
and Thank You Daisy namm director of
events as well as our visual arts
faculty and a film faculty for helping
to set that up as if Julian is a true
public intellectual from his earliest
work he has shown himself to be fearless
in his willingness to tackle
contemporary issues and to present them
in innovative forms he has never been
afraid of complexity taking strong
positions or enveloping us in beauty
only to disturb us again moments later
he is one of the most exciting artists
working today his career has spanned
film photography installation and the
installation of film he's a theorist a
writer a thinker a provocateur
identified with theoretical and artistic
discussions of gender AIDS race class
memory globalization and migration in in
vocativ forms he's also a great analyst
of the work and motivations of other
artists such as Langston Hughes and
Derek Jarman he has shown his work in
film contexts as well as in gallery and
museum settings it has been collected by
the Pompidou the Tate Modern the
Guggenheim New York the her Shawn
Deutsche Bank are
pace and so forth he's known for films
such as looking for Langston the long
road to Mazatlan France phenom black
skin white masks young soul rebels the
expedition trilogy which he will talk
about tonight and so forth nominated for
the Turner Prize and recipients of many
awards at Khan and at other important
festivals his family arrived as
immigrants from the Caribbean to England
he attended Central Saint Martin's
School of Art in London with a BA in
film and was in a postdoctoral fellow in
Brussels he has exhibited in biennials
documentas numerous group the group and
solo shows around the world he has had
and continues to have a really
extraordinary career but nothing about
his work is predictable just when the
film world or the art world thinks they
know him have seen the range of issues
and locations that concern him and the
forms that he can imagine Isaac does
something so unexpected that everyone is
amazed like the 55 minute 9 screen film
installation that he will talk to you
about this evening ten thousand waves
which I saw at the bass museum at art
basel miami last year this work was so
startling Ling gorgeous so layered and
brilliantly executed that I knew we had
to bring him to Columbia to discuss it
motivated by a tragic event that
occurred in 2004 123 Chinese immigrant
cockle pickers drowned in the north of
England ten thousand waves moves between
Chinese history the history of film the
specificity of locality the complexity
of globalization and the way citizens
are engulfed in it seducing yet refusing
to seduce it is gorgeous to watch one
moves around the space when the nine
screen installation is up to find the
perfect place to take in this radical
montage post cinematic is called by some
soon to recognize that there is no one
place and surely no perfect place angle
or vantage point at which the pieces
will all cohere such as the nature of
the world today and such as the great
strength of Iser Julian's work never
sacrificing the art for the ideas or the
ideas for the art creating an amalgam of
provocation through metaphor and
allegory that enables us to confirm
the issues he presents in all their
dimensionality so let's welcome eyes of
Julian and I'll let him tell you and
show you more isaac julien
well thank you so much uncle for that
very very kind and generous introduction
and its great honor to be here at
Columbia and to be part of this
prestigious program of world leaders
forum and I think it's very novel idea
to have artists participate because i
think we are interested in questions
that reach a certain global point or
intervention and what i would like to do
this evening is to basically just
introduce some work um western union
small birds which is just to show you
kind of ten minutes of that work and
then i'll come back and talk to you it
was a bit more about my work and
obsessively and we've talked about ten
thousand waves and were probably have a
discussion afterwards Karen I so I'm
western union small birds is a work
which I shot in 2007 I shot it in Sicily
and obsessively was looking at people
moving from the north of Africa from
Libya but they have traveled far inside
of Africa to reach their beer too as it
were try to escape Libya to get into
Europe and this of course is something
which was highlighted recently and which
I'm going to talk to you about of course
in a bit more detail but we're familiar
of what's happened in Libya and this
world which is made in 2007 in a sense I
think sort of was the country
investigation into how I felt that
Sicilian and specifically Italian
European life was in this transformation
in this kind of um moment of a
particular um sort of response to on
globalization the westin in small boats
and I'll come back thank you
ha ha Jackie DeVito polka na ma sa
kanila total Otto dance away boy allah
jalla jala
their bodies it was this event so please
Babbage's representative like a one
section companions our family rerun the
robotics functions that creep i think
every year title and a tiny tiny island
of my sister it's a libel getting an
avenue for their status
what for Arizona for elemental defeated
it
Oh
and Jesus
well
so I've been working in the era of
moving image since 1983 of course that
dates me and my work incorporates
different artistic disciplines as you
obviously um just saw drawing from
commenting on firm down to Agra music
theatre painting and sculpture and trice
unite them to create a unique paretic
visual language and topography in
audio-visual some installations and my
phone reflect upon I think New thermic
culture technique for approaching images
of other NASA as well as a showcase of
the migration of images across the
genealogies of moving images in art and
film at contacts the artistic beginnings
of my work were formed in dialogue with
the sine curve a film vehicle active
with some of the theories that were in
circulation in British cultural studies
and post-colonial studies and
psychoanalysis in the late 80s and early
90s in which my work was involved with
different traditions such as Joe Hall
comedy mercer paul gilroy I'm Barbra to
name only a few these different
conceptualizations of theory and art and
the post-colonial and the post global
art cumulated in oakland raiders
documenter 11 over a decade ago now and
of course times in Islam today artists
are confronted with an extreme dilemma
of either participating in trying to
understand and to articulate current
world crises through their work
questioning consent resumption or
embracing
more neutral position first ignoring in
some way and being complicit in non
questioning the continuation of certain
crises as LED as late Edward Gleason
said I will set the work on a GI poetics
because the joy critics can understand
world a GL politics can destroy the
world and of quiet today we embrace a
far more complicated and fragile were a
platform in which art is able to make
interventions on to the political stage
in my work throughout nearly the last 30
years I've been interested in making
political aesthetically interventions a
kind of joy poetic so I can borrow a bit
saans phrase against the global scene in
the early part of my practice I was
involved in a discussion of some
practice that of transnational T
committed to making interventions and
what had been named in other contacts as
circum Atlantic desperate cultures I
then saw cinema as a sort of critical
artistic tool that could be used as an
effective means for riata chelating the
poetics of dust boric memory but through
digital computerized revolutions even in
which culture has mutated into a digital
realm which has demanded a repositioning
of my own work into several swears and
platforms the interdisciplinary nature
of my practice hinges between film
essays work audio-visual ventilations
photography creating teaching and
talking a bit too much about what I do
and these attempts a visual
archaeological expedition of reducing
riz matic effects in transatlantic space
again to culture of hedonic structures
in effect a Roman cinematic praxis which
is moving as it were hopefully upstream
and sometimes downstream against the
tides of globalization as an artist it's
important I think to temp
to protest against the new rules of
representations defined by the
globalized networks if you don't take
such action I think that I the actual
aims order sort of forms representation
from those networks will rewrite you say
to speak and in my earlier works like
look at Langston 1989 and the Front's
venom from that skins right Martin like
96 deeds from essays recorded experience
here ism over time i would say which is
now lost perhaps to a new digital
generation which is why the issue of
multi platforms and aesthetic
interventions become important in the
digital age my interest in digital
version in similar to that of musical
version ii and in popular culture is
where the questioning of authorship to
authentic models lies it was in the
spring of nineteen ninety-seven after
making the france final film black skins
right Martha I was approached by a young
art critic ocwen razor to show a work in
the 1997 johannesburg be a gnarly where
I made a version of the documentary an
essay of two screen works from one
screen documentary could fan on sa 1997
and in the installation I obstructed a
series of images from my feature film
documentary that correspond did to a
lyrical register than the psychiatrists
and revolutionary frantz fanon's writing
the vibrancy in the sensuality of images
extracted from my earlier film were
represented in the condensed form
presenting a sort of spin or ironic
quotation on Fallon's tax quote there is
no color prodigious hair so of course it
was very kind of you know ambivalent
because it was shown just after
apartheid in 1994 and we have in the
film CREP or the two screens fan on as a
character waving the South African ANC
flag and the same work later on 2004 was
shown in an exhibition created by Mark
Nash chord experiments with truth an
exhibition which was a display of
contemporary even images intending to
reassess the influence of cinema and
documentary practices within
contemporary visual art the
reconstructed scenes in my film from
colonial wars and mental disorders
fallon's frames essay in a prophetic
sense are still now the ongoing
unfinished dialogues between the current
war and its discontents since the making
of the work time and the way that many
Warfare's have since taken place I think
we could say that in deeds increased
troubled times emergencies war
disinformation the move an image it can
represent an alternative view one in
which images can play a critical role in
shaping and understanding of the world
rather than many been used as a
secondary investment in the art market
so in the meantime one part of the
artwork artwyrd profits and its
continued march towards the auction
house this is the version that is
celebrated in our digital age in the
press especially and the complicity
between its success and the now
contaminated ward street hedge funds
continue to mass other forms of
intervention but what have the images
and in particular musin images in
contemporary art Dom to bring into focus
other interventions could the continued
resistance to move an image work by the
auction has been in fact it's saving
grace I get only history were town but
back in the 90s the gallery rather than
the cinema became an important space
making interventions to review the
different cultural political
perspectives that made up live an image
in the 2000s and in a sense we could say
that in the two founders there's a sort
of expansion into a sort of cultural
realm from moving image works from
around the world and I would argue that
a lot has changed since making films
like look as ranks
and frantz fanon in my own practice such
a change can be noted by movement from
cinema to university from the gallery to
the museum back to university and
talking to you hair this ship hierarchy
brings with it a grain sort of questions
including high we to consider the
phenomena of contemporary artists
working in from video and how did a
version of pro cinema become
increasingly calm presence within the
art gary contacts and which of course
was viewed suspiciously by some and
perhaps quite rightly said i would argue
that the distinctive experiment
approaches to visual imagery once the
aesthetic hallmarks of experimental
cinema have transcended into the space
of the contemporary global art world it
seems that of course you need or our
hands of historians who in a sense dream
but it may survive the cinema but i
would say um a lot has changed and this
grain trend I would say has been marked
to my own career as an artist a
filmmaker in 2008 I made a film to the
Swinton on Derek drama and created a
show about his work sometime gallery
london and i would argue that his death
in 1994 um for me marked the kind of
finale of an independent film culture
and UK we regrettably what the film
critic and cultural from historian rebe
rich once rightly crowned a new quest
cinema is orbit loss but traces i would
argue can be found um from the genre
which reappear here and there in
advertising in mainstream television and
galleries and through experimentations
with film and video the distinctions
between narrative avant-garde and
documentary practice become blurred
along with shifts in the views
experiences who's rien habits and
subjectivity is our influence but a new
computer and digital technology ism the
documentary turn i would argue in video
art which was perhaps hinted also by
john a decade ago in his image image
less feature film blue
with his anti representational strategy
German presented a blank screen of yves
klein blue which stood as a kind of
minimalist testament to his time lost to
AIDS by creating a blue frame where this
potato loses his or her sight in us in
the kind of blue mesh as it were this
non representational image I would argue
retain a poetical actual knowledge where
German sonically reproduce with
precision documenting his eventual
partial blindness during his battle
against AIDS blue premiered at the
venice biennale in june nineteen
ninety-three as a video installation /
train as it works the Kirlian truth
about his condition reflecting on how
artists might utilize it static
structures of moving images in order to
respond to certain political and social
conditions so looking through my own
archive look at langston frantz fanon
black skins like mass the attendant from
like 93 the works made for a discursive
space andrey articulating the politics
of queer and press clearly difference at
a time this was a response to early
developments in British cultural study
ism and I saw myself them as a artist as
a cultural worker making interventions
Eva through the language of cinema or
via the platform of progressive
television programming such as Channel 4
television where there was a sort of
early version of a digital revolution
taking place since then in our troubled
globalized times different platforms for
experimentation and even image have been
created contemporary museums galleries
or one domain where a legacy of these
innovations continues and aesthetics or
the moving image intervention take place
within its limits the politics are ever
the location Museum when vividly
signaled some time ago I'd argue in
works like that of Langston and the
attendant both films explored the
spatial-temporal allottees the quarian
history transgressing racial boundaries
and a Space Museum in the calanques and
for example sections or the black and
white
shown an art gallery in New York for 9
30 s and we see as it were
african-american artists and their
patrons whilst reads verse from Chaucer
history the smiler with the knife hidden
under cloak and here I was leading to my
suspicions of cause of the art world and
a possible dangers of patronage for
artists indeed an ironic position that
one finds oneself in emerging
displacements of cinema one's
ambivalence towards it in an art context
can be seen as a continuation of some of
my earlier cinematic concerns it could
be seen as a reconfiguration of sort
this mutation from one technology to the
other from ceroid two digit or and the
computer file makes new interventions
possible along with this are the changes
in the nature of spectatorship and
subjectivity dieter translational the
gallery means that the spectators who
come to these bases may have a different
set of expectations beyond the normative
expectations were journalists in my
audience of course that doesn't
guarantee that these new expectations
are necessarily more progressive than
earlier ones as David Joslyn expressed
in art form in March 2004 quote
projection reintroduces a more
conventional theatrical murder of sats 8
ership in which the audience remains
outside of the media feedback loop
rather than participating as actors that
within it unlike Hollywood cinema
however video projections which are
typically fractured across several
screens tend to Eve accelerate the pace
of edit sort of slowed them dramatically
fuss undermining an illusion of coherent
action and serving to disrupt the
viewers smooth absorption into a
narrative indeed in this regard as well
as it as its adherence to the planetary
or the gallery war video production is
much air to the traditions of modernist
painting as it is to successor to
closed-circuit video and required to
thinking about Jocelyn's quote i if i
can descend into a kind of more popular
culture arena and make the argument that
the ark could also be heir to sir
forms of history painting I'd like to
bend his reading to work about a museum
that I made myself in 2004 Baltimore the
aim about tomorrow large-scale free
screen with your projection was to try
to create a rereading across three
distinctive archives including that of
black patch from from from 70s the
installation aims reflector aims to
create a reflective third space using
both high in popular culture motifs such
as black science fiction after futurism
the triptych component explores the
extractives of blaxploitation cinema
onra and its contemporary references for
its use of light-hearted citations from
a number of movies the work was shot in
baltimore city of course of a long
history of black migration settlement of
course baltimore is the home base of the
n-double-a-cp in the state's the prime
locations of baltimore are the museums
of the waters art gallery and important
Renaissance art museum downtown
Baltimore the great blacks in wax museum
the equivalent of a sort of madame
tussauds gone wrong or funky Thomas
Herschel installation and it's one of
Americans african-americans top 10
history attractions and my interest in
these archives will connected to notions
of power memory mobilisation of course a
blaxploitation genre are profound
imperfect and contaminated culturally
sexist yet queer and certainly not
everyone would call these films art nor
many of them that companion I'd argue
that this is relevant these forms
available provide a rich starting point
for one's own imagery they involved with
the aesthetics of the vulgar video
projection can draw attention to the
visual identifiers and codes which i
reworked to produce at realized vision
of the museum the piece I hope is
received as a provocative and satiric or
intervention within the art world
critically rearranging and untidy in its
character endeavors a critique of museum
critique or institutional critique
itself the idea behind the first part of
my back
i vas project was to place the
documentary badass in the law in a
pedagogical relationship to the
spectator I wanted to share their
archival process the power of the visual
iconography in relation to the artifacts
of the sixties and seventies Black Power
movement to people's lives to their very
representation this attempt aquarian
blaxploitation imagery is an
acknowledgement of its past abilities
influence other genres such as hip-hop
and independent film and so on I also
wanted to consider the misunderstandings
and complexities of the genre through
interviews with black stars such as Pam
Grier engage in debate and dissension
badass anomaly enables acetate to fully
appreciate the spatial-temporal allottee
about most multiple screens and sonic
sound projections and I'm for
criticality that tackles deformed
representation or strategy is inherent
in blaxploitation films themselves and
approximate sees aesthetics or the space
of video art their scenes in Baltimore
short with deliberate by jetta key facts
that were to disrupt narrative tell us
the camera truck movements within the
frame make use of the sculpture
potential cinematic space in the
triptych format the images and not
merely representations of certain black
iconic iconic types but representations
answer spaces or representations and
here the political figures architectural
spaces Renee's on paintings i
specialized and collated across all
three screens and mirrors the visual
ideas on perspective from the school of
Perea della Francesca as an idol city
this is achieved through pictorial
montage in order to emphasize the
politics of the spatial urban scene
particular to Baltimore Marvin van
people's plays the main protagonist for
the element of the unexpected along with
Vanessa Meyer he plays a kind of part
black thumb to tell part Andrew Davis
pot Foxy Brown parts I bored her
character as it were remains out of
sexual reach for Melvin her sexuality is
enigma for some but not for all of
course these characters are indeed
haunted by the history and its base of
the museum and their own filmic
iconicity
moving through the museum space into the
world stage derma in which artists and
filmmakers now find themselves the
global scenario is one in which certain
debates conducted rather notional
citizenship the state of its ception in
which we now live in the Americas Europe
between South and North I felt compelled
to question the laissez-faire attitude
that had been developed I call it boda
border phobia which runs in contestation
to the way in which the Trump flis
debates about new technologies continues
as bodies follow information and capital
flows one of the major questions arising
from this development is the part that
individuals may play in this flow
information questions surrounding the
circulation of human lies the movements
of bodies that person stories are timely
when immigration policies still generate
controversy on a daily basis and eat a
successful right winged victory ism the
relationship between nations of course
dabassisst or this was much debate and
such important geopolitical questions
often avoid addressing or giving voice
and image to the individual and dare I
say geo pratik human qualities which are
lost amongst the noise of political
pronouncements of course we assume a
certain political correct representation
or aesthetic position on such debates
western union or Burt's proposes to get
back to a very imagistic level where
individual voyages journey isn't travel
I explored locally in order to lead to
the global scenario in a census of work
that traces the effects of trauma not
just in people but also embroiled in zin
monuments and architecture the krog
raphy by relocating these themes in a
representational non-narrative manner
indeed Platzer gangi is a real important
point which is a plateau which appears
in visconti's masterpiece the leopard is
indeed a starting point for a
visualization of Western unions
more birds which examines a cinematic
afterlife haunted by characters from
other places and other films other parts
of the globe two women one black one
white wonders loss reader platzer gangi
the grandeur of the interiors opulent
and luxurious now abandoned space
etching with the ghosts of it were
decadent imperial average times we had a
score from the leopard but these rooms
are not empty and resonate with Sicilian
history of migration to the New York and
other cities in the US I collaborated
also with a renowned choreographer
Guatemala found and his dance company
and corridor choreographed a series of
vignettes in some locations in the film
utilizing dance movement of bodies at
Queen DS journeys were also real tickle
ating them for cinema on stage a live
version of Western Union small pets was
performed live at bam in 2007 called
Costner shadow part of performer B&R in
2007 Western in small bursts of course
concerns journeys across the seas of the
Mediterranean of circle clandestine who
left Libya escaping wars and famines and
may just work in 2007 in France of the
Irish Spring of 2011 and looking back in
hindsight sometimes works have a sort of
prophetic aspect to them the circle
clandestine stand could be seen I'd
argues economic migrant workers along
with certain Europeans angels in water
Benjamin's terms who bears witness to
modernity its failed hopes and dreams
who now travel across oceanic spaces
some never arrive or to return kampa
bianca is a sight of Adriana story who
is Vanessa mayuri's character of how she
came to Agrigento southwest of Sicily we
see a beautiful coastline a beach of
holidaymakers an iconic scene of
picturesque beauty but what kind of bear
life lies here in this landscape of
vacation bless her journeys alluded to
shoot
sound collage a montage techniques a
multiple prismatic views with pictorial
references to the sea fishing nets a
hand grasping and that about clinging
letting go the back of her head under
the hot day some and to see in its moody
deathly manifestations western you know
Burt's focuses specifically on the
effects of how such journeys and the
clandestine as it were who become boat
wrecked on the coast of Sicily just off
the iron of land producer a hundred
miles away from North Africa which is
one of the main points for entry for
clandestine from Asian Africa who are
trying to reach Europe around 2007 and
in 2007 um the Libyan Civil War of
course um we have seen thousands of
people who've left camps in Libya they
set out of course in larger birds and
download transformed midsi to highly
overcrowded small efficient birds where
they left to drift for days on end until
I spotted by coast guards or sink
fishermen have been as it were the
frontline of what is frequently
described by the Italian media as a
Sicilian hunter cause as they often spot
these boats first and in this work I
hint at these new configurations and
traumas in elliptical manner Western Ian
Alberto forms nearly the final
installment of this trilogy of
audio-visual film insulations which also
includes true north of phantom a freak
2004-2005 respectively the works explore
the impact of location above culture and
physical to Assad an effect for a
juxtaposition of globe or regions to
know for shot into spectacular
landscapes of Iceland and northern
Sweden was conceived around expedition
and writings of Matthew Henson when the
key members Robert E Perry's 1909 Arctic
expedition Henson was controversially
and arguably the first person to reach
North Pole he was also african-american
and the basis of my research what its
work actually comes from an interview
conducted here at Columbia by University
student Robert H file entitled
the Negro who went to the power with
Perry this interview conducted in 1953
when hansoms 85 two years before his
death forms the voice-over narration to
work in a kind of subtle Sansa true nor
false alludes to shifts of eyes of /
environment and underscores the grain
need to understand the environment as
ice melts in both regions to articulate
an Arctic have once again become objects
of international competent competition
as well as size of research and concern
of which the Deathly sublime lurks an
economic gain as it were mounts phantom
afree the second word expedition trilogy
weaves cinematic and architecture
references or through the rich imagery
of urban Waka dugar the capital of
Burkina Faso in West Africa and the
center facism are for the whole of
Africa with the perk up with the back
bisogna Film Festival the city center
location is contrasted in the world with
the arid rural space of Burkina Faso the
firm is punctuated by archival footage
from early clarinets petitions and lund
landmark moments in African history true
north of phantom everybo commissioned
and sharing together as a large scale
for screen insulation phantom girl that
had sent to Pompidou in Paris in 2005
and at the her Sean's recent exhibition
death cinema effect real isms in 2008
the question of location travel and
global Agra fees are also part of the
architectural structure of how the works
are shown for example the multiscreen
installation of phantom creo which
combines phantom african true north
employed one dream flynner or what I
called a Creole foreigner who
transgresses geographical boundaries
between north and south as well as
metaphorically speaking the images
frames this creates a dissonance between
his and her geographical trespassing
were not being or becoming far apart of
geography that he or she comes to
inhabit
hence the globe or and the locals well
as a subjectivity that is associated
with it as part of its territories is
not only renegotiated in these visual
topographical landscapes but is
transformed into a kind of critical
trance locality a kind of geopolitics
the question of trans Macavity is not
only Geographic but also architectural
II through the design of the space of
the installation itself and the way in
which to work through installed for
example in western in small birds which
can be seen as a single screen in a film
contacts in its version as leopard or
free of five screen projection which
specially designed 5.1 surround sound
can figure according to the museum space
which is presented the aim of retina
small birds tends towards a
non-representational suggestive rather
than the strictly narrative and small
birds is not about storytelling as such
but about creating environment through
which an accumulation sensations images
and sound creates a complex thought
provoking intriguing work I hope in
contrast the whiteness and clarity of
true north and visual vibrancy of
phantom a freak the installation of
these works are realized in such a way
that it's hope that on the one hand the
viewer form new emphatic identifications
was on the other the experience of these
images from an unexpected point of view
is hoped and also one hopes that the
audiences are able to gain a better
understanding or the context surrounding
them this is achieved not only through
the images and the surrounding sound but
what's the true experience in the design
of the installation itself in terms of
both way one enters the space in
relationship to the screened and
arrangement the screens and the sound
which remaps a new site for witnessing
journeys which may be well known but a
sword amused as the basis for art
experience in a gallery contacts
better life in 2010 is a single screen
reinterpretation of my 9 screen
insulation 10,000 waves which was
selected to be shown last year at the
Venice Film Festival shot on location in
China the work proactively weaves
together with China's ancient past and
present for a 9 screen architectural
installation that induces essentially
navigational component to them even
image this work explores the movement of
people across countries and continents
and like Western Union small birch shows
how unfinished journeys and hence his
stories are being meditated and I
suggest a sort of meta ethnographic and
person emetic reading in moving image
art said that the work might acquire
qualities of a post global visual
culture as of stencil category of a new
aesthetics of imagism in fact the
original inspiration for ten thousand
waves was a more convey tragedy of 2004
oh i should say crime in which 23
chinese kaka Shoppach has died and
following existential ideas around deaf
and spiritual displacement and you
uniquely chinese connection with ghosts
on lost souls this work links the
Shanghai of the past and present that
symbolizes in the Chinese tradition
towards modernity aspiration and
inference the so-called better life I
employed a visual language in cinematic
translation of ghost stories which
recurrent figures and images apparent
and discipline rhythmically as well as
spatially forming a new category the
legendary goddess mazel spectral figure
played by maggie cheung transversus time
and space serving as a guide through the
interlocking strands of the work she
acts as a protector goddess who like the
more convey workers originates from the
Fujian province mirroring the goddess of
the fey but a ghostly protagonists Jesus
through the world of Shanghai cinema
fired the Shanghai film studio to a
restaging scenes from the Chinese film
classic the God
19-24 and finally to the streets of
modern and edgy Shanghai however the
archival police footage which appears at
the beginning of the work as well as the
original emergency cause and helicopter
footage from the bird's eye view creates
a distressing dissonance as an air
relationship between the different cases
these airborne viewpoints represent the
single screen version of 10,000 ways
better live recap slates the modes of
classical cinematic pairings the author
as direct an editor are intentionally
translated the work for multi-screen
format a single screen so as to face
unique as it were rewarded inland set of
challenges from the practical to the
faretta core from one media format the
other from single screen as a
predominant cinematic space to the
multiscreen as paradigm of moving image
artists elations in the gallery comtex
result i hope is that Domanick lee we
edited single screen film that succeeds
in use in the classical tools or
experimental narrative cinema and
translates complex matrices of ideas
into multimedia art works fast better
life becomes a further version in or
articulation of ten thousand waves
project moving as it were between the
worlds of art from and music and
emphasizes the importance of
collaboration in my practice this open
this also represents a different
artistic and aesthetic somatic platforms
from which to work can be seen in
various transmutations ad in live
performance music event as part of the
works genesis and irrelevance of the
sonic dimension of the work for example
chopped in shanghai B&R in 2010
performed computerized soundtrack for
the work as swedish composers death an
austin j and henrik fresh also created a
live sound interpretation for the film
which was performed at the Guttenberg
Banali earlier this year the project was
conceived and made over four years and
in that I collaborated with some I must
say of Chinese lead in artistic voices I
was very fortunate
able to work with someone that Maggie
Chong and also to work with the rising
star of Chinese cinema is our tower also
Wang ping the poet who formed the
narration of the world the muscular
calligrapher gone for gone and also
artists yung su dong and also with a
Chinese crew of over 100 people so the
film's original musical score is
actually designed by a fellow East
Londoner Jaguar and the Chinese dub
Orchestra and I also collaborated with
the contemporary classical composer
Maria they are there he performed a live
event at Rennes associa um tuition
islanders are sort of another version as
it were of the work ten thousand ways
first creates a particular scenarios and
spaces the abstraction of geographical
realities in the media encounter with
the Chinese work in a global narrative
context that of course defines our new
global era yet the question of
subjectivity remains a focus in my work
which is reflected in expressed through
elements of desire in the context of how
one achieves a better life in a global
culture of indifference an aesthetic
level I employ digital technologies
developed form elements such as color
para montar and sound to conceptualize
the different global discourse is the
editing process in which I engage as it
were different forms of architectural
space well as I edit some of screens
across it at one time the question of
simultaneous locality and dis local t
into text relations multi-screen
speciality creates a conversation
between the themes and discourses in
translation as well as aesthetic
strategies while in acting a dynamism
that transgresses the boundaries between
the different media furthermore the gays
and it's reticle underpinnings have been
an ongoing focus in my work in 10,000
ways I'm also as were trans cultural
conversation rest
and I'm also contaminated by at where
the 30 shanghainese cinema and also in
conversation of contemporary insulation
works by major artists such as junk food
on who also appears in the work and this
lettuce larger cinematic and
contemporary art is achieved through
various archival references through a
process of suturing for example zaltar
and Young's we'd all have tea and a
sumptuous Red Palace a scene which is in
the cup of archival footage of the
Cultural Revolution with references to
litter RT aesthetics which of course
we're oppressed by mal at the end of the
sequence we cut to the last story in ten
thousand waves a television island where
we see a green spatial drown in sequence
Maggie chanas mizzou den and finally cut
to the footage from a Hong Kong
documentary about the Morecambe Bay
tragedy during the intention of this
montage was to suture different
sequences in such a way that past
present reciprocally look at each other
and create a critical commentary the
documentary first becomes in a debts a
core element that cuts into the
reconstruction scenes of yishun Island
because for me it's important for the
documentary footage to be inserted as a
flash fraud in physical time connecting
China's history of migration to the 15th
century to present Bay in fact the
television island from the Ming period
is set in the past and hence this flash
forward connects distell to the present
day went to the Chinese shot
because at Morecambe Bay I thought that
there is something annika ristic about
the Philip dependent ideas around the
migration and globalization the question
of realism in these debates about
globalization is a pressing one and it
is always discussed in relation with the
artists intention but I feel that I'm
also involved in a certain type of
aesthetics that is connected to merge or
translating ideas and politics in a way
that questions dis realism as authentic
to the construction of pollen
my work is connected to a pratik
rendition of meditation on particular
charge questions for recourses sublime
and also worked on a meta-narrative
level by evoking for example mizzou a
figure who still worship today in
southeast china i think i'm able to
converse with historical legacy of how
people from the Fujian province have
moved through time and space that for
thousands of years and of course
immigration debate is just historically
outdated in this context historically of
course the tragedy is but one among many
that is widely under the ten thousand
ways I reveal the goddess in a
green-screen stage that deconstructing
the myth as typical practive ice of
course fantasy is vertical a debris has
not seen the type of way to discuss
global politics since Contemporary Art
discourses around such subjects tend to
veer towards a relationship between
realism and aesthetics which I believe
certain classes or groups associate with
the guilty lock mhmm referencing James
need armed who wrote about King Cole and
the question of pleasure and violence
that his sort of figure created for um
sort of cinema in my view fantasy is
political allegory in artistic practice
in a global context can be effectively
provocative and alluring and a subtle
tool for making political interventions
a sort of reparation or aesthetics which
might as it were kind of contest a
really strategy which would be deemed
more appropriate essentially I see all
the images being constructed whether
they are documentary or fiction it's
that one form has dominated way we could
collectively think about globality they
are all fabricating a political a
particular point of view it's that one
is a genre that we could call
documentary the other one is more
stylized in form yet the fact that I po
certain political questions forests are
lights lyrical formation is probably
what is unusual in ten thousand waves my
brick a large approach of various
intertextual sources of
textures along with elements of fantasy
essentially takes the work into the
realm of the hyperbolic representation a
kind of mythological poetics of
reparation of course the news critism of
my work is that returns us as a question
of his fatigues to make something
beautiful out of the human relation how
can this be politically progressive I
want to turn head to Jennifer a gonzalez
who concludes in her essay see dreams
when she's discussing wesleyan small
birds quote and what of the molar corn
are tistic cinematic tradition that has
depicted tragedy and human suffering for
centuries trillions work engages this
long tradition but also speaks of a new
a media-saturated meant where all kinds
of violence appears to set aside and
normalized it's precisely this
normalization of violence in popular
culture that may function to mask the
real violent of the international
politics by producing an airy sculpture
excessive representation to drown in
body the choreography of the dancers
invites us a glimpse of violence we can
only otherwise distantly imaginal it is
important therefore that we are immersed
with these bodies in the projected with
your environment there cooperatively
there corporal T dominating the space we
place in temporary fictions of
nationality with the Unforgiven see a
substance that promises both life and
death end of quote so the question of
the statics of representations at the
heart of the engagement of my visual
practice it is rather about negotiations
of content the question of being what
artists attic politics at stake in an
artist creative response to the turmoil
and turbulence of our global culture
today thank you
Oh God yummy
Connie please come back i'ma cook the
cockle pickers and the music I you know
something big enough to get along today
well they can go do it be time for that
he's on the beach cabin fever operate on
the way to take them off now right I
mean to me to get over it another funny
because I'll Kabul being with you please
come out there now about these are out
there you know how many many five people
rather depend on the cockle bed up their
bark of that yes choco pies welcome back
ok
applicant
keep on their bike
hello
wait
bartender module Nathan of silence hear
the plea of your supplying children our
bones shadow upon the rocks our souls
scatter across the ocean nothing is left
of us only are I facing east from the
seafloor a breath drifting from shore to
shore
omar to her
Mother of mercy please shine the light
on the marquee see take us home under
the dragon I tree oh we sweep sweeping
with threshing whores we will not rest
till we reach the land of yellow earth
please you are just arriving on scene
now
welcome Chinese nationals can't play
will speak English poster
please
one person only in this stage
she'll be eliminating my RSS flight
the
I
can't
what
Musa Dagh
how violent
with job I talked with yola Wow argentea
trilling the job dangers helping
Suetonius ability to quit
is that we are told her my word amo tell
you how she said you should
I antal point one tire
she later mishka hydration how to quit
you iphone Korean soldier
has shown to all you do so i'll say so
well
he seemed a good wouldn't eat oh
hi whoreson daughter who died argentea
place a walk yes confirm our continuing
with thermal search of the area for
others
we know the toes 23 Rockaway New York 58
Dover England 1825 South Korea and many
more we know the methods swim fly metal
container back of Laurie ship's hold we
know how they died stop suffocated
homesick Hartzog worked to death working
to death we know we may end in the same
boat
Mayo cool down it's why me or shoot you
sakamoto tell me about 72 son
you
Oh
o young loso two ago she know go to
Quogue when Romeo patent for sure mom
evita tag warm ice Sunni sucks
and I heard obey from hehe no one paid
wore a yellow sari through bait how so
humid highs oh gr y mo yet
what when you see you do mom adaline one
shall know that bit where sure Lucinda
tossed from the Communist path we chose
the capitalist world who quit Paris all
we want is alive like others TVs cars a
house bigger than our neighbors now the
tide is rising to my knees ice forming
in our chess
no exit no moon to point our path to
flee from the angry North Wales see
i don't know i mean it it might be hard
for people to understand if you don't
know the incident that occurred with the
cockle pickers could you talk about
could we make the lights a little bit
less could you talk a little bit about
why they got stranded because it's such
an amazing metaphor in it might not be
clear to people not seeing and hearing
the whole the whole narrative yes and I
think sort of i mean i kind of said at
the beginning it's a tragedy but
actually i should correct myself and say
it was a crime because essentially what
was being performed apart from the
attempt for kind of struggling for a
better life was the fact that they had
been taken from the Fujian province by
gangmasters and then they were brought
to UM Morecambe Bay to north of England
and because of their lack of knowledge
of how the coastal tides worked um were
set to work at a particular time when it
endangered them and this in a way sort
of um sort of brought interview the kind
of loophole really you know through law
and also the fact that you know this is
the kind of work in practice which is
turned a blind eye to and the gang
bosses were tried and they served prison
sentences for manslaughter and so
basically you know this um was a very
much publicized to the in a political
sort of scam door and something in the
people in the United States don't know
quite as well I think as people in
England my microphone keeps and in fact
something that in a way in China wasn't
that well no actually and that was one
of the reasons in fact why some people
became very interested in worked with me
on the project because of course in it
it would be one among many such events
in china but i think that people just
moved by this idea of
this you know notion of lost souls and
also um I think people were sort of very
sort of interested in the fact that I
would want to do something like this and
with attempt this sort of research the
kind of looking at mizzou as a looking
at dis from a slightly different um view
from a Western point of view Mars is the
goddess mother goddess it's such an
amazin I wanted you to tell that story
is that it's so it's such a metaphor for
everything about globalization and those
who get caught by those who are willing
to exploit them and then get caught in
cultural disconnect where were they
indigenous to the area they would know
the tired patterns it wouldn't be
something unknown they wouldn't have
been caught in that situation were they
able to speak the language where they'd
have had cell phones but all of those
things that we see constantly every day
in the news of narrative and and I also
know that your own family came from the
Caribbean right so it must have some
residents some resonance for you they
are as well no absolutely amazing
there's way in which you know waited
this event unfolded and of course if we
think about the role of the sea and
ocean in this um event of course that
very much reverberates so in early works
that I've made and works like paradise a
morose and even western union small
birds and of course you know is that
Walcott's poem sort of Tarsus to see is
history you know and said there's way in
which there was this sort of real
connection with the ways in which I
thought this was an event that sort of
had certain parallels um sort of in
other works and of course yes my friends
came to England on a boat and so it has
that sort of certain resonance
I like what you said about geo poetics
as opposed to geopolitics I thought that
was really beautiful because you know
sometimes people think it's odd you said
it to me we were talking earlier about
the world leaders forum you know that
you're the second artist that we brought
last year with alfredo jaar and I don't
think in the history of the world
leaders forum before that there were
artists but in my mind artists are
leading in asking the really complex and
sophisticated questions about issues
like globalization but from the very
human level and that's where the poetics
come in and that's where the images come
in and you talked about you talk about
architecture and texture and everything
human everything about the body and
everything that's beautiful and
everything that's ugly and all of it
comes together in these amazing
narratives that you construct and then
deconstruct and then construct again and
the thing that's hard as you say it's
like seeing a slide what's hard to
imagine is when you see them that
they're so big those screens are so big
that when you see the see you fall right
into the sea and when the goddess is
flying she's flying right towards you
when you're seeing it at that scale so
it's hard from here so I love that term
because I think that's that is what
artists can contribute is this geo
poetics which you've taken so seriously
everything you've done in your life and
I know you get attacked or accused or
criticized for beauty too much beauty
and what you do so would you talk about
that a little bit because it's been such
an issue in the various art world's and
since you hover between so many I'm sure
you've been hit with it many times but
well I think that in a sense um I was
very so interested to news lately room
Edward we saw kind of phrase of the GI
poetics because I think there's a way in
which um if we're looking at certain
questions um I'm especially in an art
contest there is a certain vogue for the
documentary and they think that the
documentary has an important role to
play an indeed in many works there's a
sort of mixture between fiction and
documentary in the
works that I may but I think one of the
things that I want to sort of move
beyond is really in a census way of
looking at what is news report in
absentia flee and looking through these
questions in the sort of ethnographic
frame you know and that's where the
questions realism comes into play and
they think either in a way there's a
certain i don't like Newton attempt
politically correct but it in a way is a
version of that we're certain questions
can be posed with in certain sort of
aesthetic strategies which you know
people confer as it were comfortable
with and so that's why I news this term
the sort of guilty look it's really the
way thats of other groups of people or
other locations um classes a look at
difference in its many manifestations B
Class B it kind of ratio be it sort of
economic beach and a geopolitical sense
and in a way associate a certain
progressive aesthetics with that kind of
form if you like that form of
intervention and so I think in the kind
of works which I'm interested in I'm
interested in me beyond that the
Expediency of the sort of just an
ethnographic frame so to speak and a
realist frame into a move which is in
any way more lyrical more poetical but
in a sense is concerned about what I'm
calling a kind of reparation or
aesthetic approach which moves beyond
that sort of immediate see that you get
usually in a kind of more documentary
report reportage mode which is like a
certain virgam if you think about the
last Berlin be a gnarly you know you
have the idea of video works a moving
image works which have this sort of
aesthetic strain and that scene I think
in some cases rightly so as a certain
move but I think this is where we get to
the point of how then one gets construct
did if one is posing questions in that
sort of aesthetical realm of operatic
role because you know I'm interested in
poetry I'm interested in perjury and
that's obvious from looking for Langston
in 1989 I'm today walcott collaboration
with me in paradise onerous in two
thousand two and two um when ping and
her work on ten thousand waves in 2010
and so it is a way of really sort of
trying to translate and also meditate on
these questions and in ways of alibis
ation of the news so to speak an
allegation of the news everyone it's
wonderful so just I'm gonna ask you one
more thing and then I'm going to open it
what do you think about I mean you've
moved into the art world in big time
with this installation because it can't
it's not an easy thing to bring you know
it's it's going to have to be a big
museum or just to have it just to see it
in the totality the production value
that has to be so good for it to work so
it's not mobile in the way that a film
is mobile can't be shown in just any
venue although you've worked very hard
to make many adaptations so you've
entered the economy of the art market
which I know you have certain
ambivalence about so how do you feel
about that well I think in a way I mean
is why I resort to this question of
version in of the fact that you can have
a single screen version of work that
chosen a film festival contacts it can
show on television it can be no B sham
laptop you know so I do finish something
about digitalization which calls into
question the idea of the original and I
think there's a way in which sort of if
I think obsessively about the ways in
which this wind aesthetics of
interventions there's a way in which one
plays between the kind of more classic
or I'm calling normative ways in which
people read images because you know we
coming to cinema you know we sit down I
mean I think that question entertainment
is sort of there lurking behind as it
were but I think also for me what I've
been interested in the move in
relationship to shame mother scream
earth is really how one can question or
form a certain dissonance in terms of
the cognitive that there's a play with
the cognitive in relationship to the
visual and that this is something that
is worth exploring and one can explore
in a museum and gallery contacts and I
think also when I think about sort of
where are the sort of where innovation
taking place in the moving image it
seems to me that obsessively at one
point it was in the same model that the
Ellen God was located there but I think
it shifted then you have Steve McQueen
and Sharon making feature films yeah
going from installation to film but I
think you know that this movement this
crisscross movement is one when we're
one doesn't really have to choose you
know where you can as it were make
interpersonally interdisciplinary
interventions you know and have this in
a way multi-touch draw approach you know
and I think you know with the moving
image that's wishin that one you know
can a certain extent enjoy and sort of
make why not so in my own work I mean
Derek drama documentary is a documentary
it shown on television it showing film
festivals you can download it you know
on the Sundance Channel so I mean I
think you know there is that sort of
movement life that fluidity I think but
I do think however that certain sort of
critical questions around sort of vision
sort of more avant-garde questions that
I'm not so sure how they're being played
out in that sort of cinema arena
let's let's let's see what people want
to ask the floor what you up
one of the questions that carol was
asking and asked you to revisit it by
way of a term that you introduced in
your formal remarks which is this notion
of fantasy a very rich notion on any
number of levels because there's a sense
in which your practices very much about
the rejection of an ethnographic
aesthetics but it's also about the
practice of a certain aesthetic politics
and I see that really keenly in this
last project which I had not seen before
let you brought us excerpts from because
it addresses a theme that now that i
think about it has been present in your
work all along which is this question of
human rights so i'm just curious you
know to what extent do you think it
might be productive to see what you're
doing as a kind of aesthetic politics
which is motivated by the desire to
achieve a kind of aesthetic justice
right we think about this crime as you
call it that occurred as a consequence
of illegal trafficking illegal labor etc
what does your aesthetic practice or
your engagement with these questions of
human rights justice and injustice bring
in the way of allowing us to imagine to
fantasize if you will the question of
human rights that is not possible in
other form in any other form in the form
for example in which I as a legal
academic would talk about it you want to
say a few words about that
yeah I think so important they think in
a way its emulate sub hinted at it which
is um I think I guess what up says I
think there's a certain political
expediency at work usually in reporting
has to be quirky its hair today gone
tomorrow so I think in terms of
Morecambe Bay tragedy or crime we can
see that there were these responses to
it and you know there's two thousand
four you know came and went and in a way
i'm very interested in that kind of
focus that gives it a kind of a time
that has a certain longevity and i guess
if i go into a place like the loser i
see a painting like the RAF the Medusa
you know I can see that encapsulated
between that paint in a certain themes
which resonate today and I'm so I think
there's a way in which that in some
cases as a row that sort of art can play
in giving this kind of longevity and
this question of what I'm calling
reparation you know and I'm using the
term of preparation with fedex as a form
of meditation or you could you could say
it's a morning but I can see in other
forms of sort of art and so the Blues
would be one version of it you know that
you have um sort of as it were um as
sunlight strange fruit which is both the
prime and also has the question of
Anatolia and morning attached ribbit
also quite a bit a beautiful song so I
think there's this sort of aspect of you
know it's fedex that i want to give to
the world as opposed to what ice
associated I don't describe as a sort of
you know the guilty look which is this
more ethnographic frame in which would
be deemed appropriate for some for such
subject matter
you know as I think that and then I
think also it needs RM Williams time
it's a structure the feeling that can
also be attached and 2 d's kind of
moments as well and so does way in which
one is kind of plain these themes
through and also I think there's a way
in which one is also trying to challenge
of course um the sort of more consensual
assumptions about how certain debates
are sort of placed you know so they
divide between aesthetics and politics
between beauty and sort of truth yeah so
I think there's that of aspect which I
too in a way deliberately want to bring
into kind of bricolage um in the work
and I think you know that's because of
the position that one is trying to make
the work from blur as opposed to making
the work about certain things so I think
there's that different as well
first thank you so much for sharing some
of your works with us tonight I thought
that was a very rare and inspiring
opportunity and reflecting on your over
from earlier films that you discussed
and also more current multi-screen video
installations such as Western Union
small boats and then also ten thousand
waves I feel like there is a very
distinct trajectory of evolving
techniques and multiple perspectives and
then also new nuance layers of meaning
and I'm wondering given this palpable
evolution how you may be currently
experimenting with the aesthetic and
technological aspects of your digital
communication or perhaps how you may
imagine them evolving and transforming
in the future well I think there's a way
in which um that the way that the
digital has as it were kind of been part
of our has seeped into our subjectivity
is that you know every day everybody's
on the computer on Facebook you're
emailing so this kind of question the
multiscreen aspect is something that
we're all involved in you know so we're
all involved in its kind of visual
intertextual playing as a world so I
think that is obviously something that
seeped into the kind of display of the
work and obviously i think in
relationship to UM the image you know
the movement from film to digital to
files and i think there's a way that
certainly within computerization that is
some very exciting possibilities but for
my next work i'm quite interested in the
use of 3d but not in the way in which
it's used in the kind of conventional
sort of hollywood cinema contacts
because it tends to always use 3d as a
way of invading the space thats Sarah
spectator but really the use of it in
terms of deep focus and long shots and
in this kind of
and so I think this is very interesting
and I'm knifing already there is the
kind of shift between the ways in which
certain that artists like stand-up tour
example is really i think you know in a
very in a kind of frontier position in
terms of the way that he works of time
and narrative and a way that um he
introduces against the logical to lube
this sort of approach where there's a
much more of a kind of backed a
bacterium approach he's very interesting
Beckett but this approach to narrative
where it's kind of never the same you
know on each viewing you know that
player of climate and temporal at ease I
think all of these things are very
interesting and suggests moves in the
way in which sort of digitech knowledge
in computerization has really is
enhancing some even images of course you
know there's the kind of other effect
which we know that you know it's numbing
audiences and you hey we heard that it's
lulling people after thinking as well so
I mean it's a non-neutral technology
sort of the advances in digital
communication and so I think there's
also that sort of quandary as well we'll
take one more question if there is one
out there
back that way that
Isaac thanks for showing the the film
that ten thousand waves it's actually
the first time i ever seen it and um
it's really quite powerful and I've got
actually two questions first is um I
noticed that there is a beautiful kind
of a poetry in Chinese in the in the
clips that you showed and is there a
reason why they were not translated
because to a you know to a Chinese a
native speaker I understand it I you
know it adds to the film to the piece
but or is it your intention that you
think the the image will actually
transcend the verbal language and my
second question is the first time I
actually know about your work is that
upon a gallery visit on metro pictures
and I saw the stills they were so
beautiful and and but I didn't know the
story the back story which I learned
tonight and would you consider that a
separate body of work because without
the film without them you know
installation that dimension it's it
pretty much becomes a painting a tableau
if if you will I'm so what do you think
of that thanks good questions I thought
you know I think so I mean it's
interesting because i have to say that i
did ask the question myself or viewing
it in this context you know being in
American contacts and I mean work is
shown at the I say Boston um and what we
do when we show the work is that we kind
of basically print arm banking's poems
both in English and in Mandarin and so
basically you can take this away free
because basically the tax is a poem of
Stanley in terms of what's being sort of
communicated I mean I don't think that
the image can translate what's being
said and I think you can get you know
certain feelings but in terms of that
knowledge no but I think also there's a
kind of positioned I'm still quite
interested in which is that
don't think everything I'm interested in
kind of untranslatable it t as well you
know in in the sense that depending
where the work is shown if it's in
Shanghai for example where it's been
shown tonight scream work in a single
scream work then you could say that the
sort of sort of Sodom and dream speakers
would understand the English you know
and so in a way there's a kind of play
in this sort of global scene or scenario
in which to work is being sort of viewed
but i think this question of translation
of always having knowledge and access is
not possible as well you know so you
know in a way I think this question of
things of the information to be
translated in a ways in some aspects
goes against I think some of the
synthetic choices and in some ways
political choices are making in the work
because I think I was um there-there are
knowledge is that are not easily
translatable as well you know but I mean
that said there is usually attacks that
people take away to read and understand
the for parent because you know it's
important in fact the single screen
version when it's shown in the film our
context we did translate that you know
so kind of you don't have a text at
speedy you can take away but it's shown
in that context and I said what about
the images that's what the the question
was related in some way that when you
see just the photographs mmm that you
saw at Metro pictures I guess without
the installation without the film how do
you feel about that when one doesn't
have the context for those photographs
yeah I mean I think so you did it when
we show the work we show the
installation sometimes we share the
photographs in tandem and so you have
this of coral a
racial and obscenity one reasons why we
didn't try to work in my trip pictures
it occurs they had been shown in Miami
at the bass museum and also the space of
that gallery isn't really large enough
and conducive to I'm showing the work
but also in conversation with a museum
here in New York about trying to work as
well so I think in that context then
they will be able to show the nine
screen work but in a way the photographs
in a way they're kind of you could call
them souvenirs or something to that
effect you know they're kind of not the
work that's that they're separated the
ten thousand waves is a series and in a
way their photographs and in a way they
have another life as it were to the
project so in that sense they're not a
kind of literal translation of the film
they're kind of they have another medium
and there's a working in sort of another
area and they're not film stills really
other they have taken at the same time
when the film shot but they're sort of
really been at them it's my interest in
photography really dumb to the
foreground in in that contacts Isaac
it's a pleasure it's a pleasure to hear
you think in such a complex way about
everything it's really exciting it's
inspiring makes me want to go home and
write thank you for everything thanks
for tonight thank you